[Music]
Super Smash Bros ultimate is finally out
on Nintendo switch and the game
possesses three endings for its story
mode world of light throughout this
video I'll be breaking down everything
that you need to know about the games
bad badder and true ending as well as
how to get each one they will of course
be heavy spoilers so if you haven't
completed the game then I highly
recommend that you turn off now but for
everyone else
I'm definition and welcome to the
channel where I roon it so you don't
have to so let's start with the bad
ending in order to get this a players
must first face and defeat golem in the
final stretch of the game golem is a
being of light and it puts up one hell
of a fight players must dodge all kind
of projectiles and more to survive but
those who finally manage to defeat the
character will witness dark on capture
golem and imprison it with the being of
light now gone from the universe
darkness beautiful beautiful darkness is
able to spread and in the finale it
seems like every character has been
corrupted mario falls face first on the
ground and presumably dies and we get a
final shot of our new dark lord and
savior dark on who is finally here to
completely ruin the world worse than a
teresa may bracket deal there's no extra
life this time and it's a pretty dour
waiter in the game but luckily that
isn't the only ending that completely
ruins everything
juxtaposing the bad ending if characters
take on dark on then they will be
treated to a slightly better ending
maybe not I mean they're both as bad as
each other and getting this ending is a
lot easier said than done
dark on is one of the toughest battles
in the entire game and he's just as hard
to take down as galine was those who
tough it out though I managed to beat
dark on will witness a scene where
gallium destroys it and its forces
sending them into the ocean well it's
this might have seemed like an easy
choice that would result in a happy
ending it does quite the opposite upon
winning galine will send a huge beam of
light out that destroys our heroes then
the earth then the entire universe
yup it's all your fault you've
completely ruined everything and that's
the good ending apparently in the games
true ending both darken and gleam are
defeated to get this takes a bit of
manipulation of the board and players
will have to ensure that before they go
into the final fight that the spirits
are equal on both sides you can tell
this to you to their coloring of either
black or white with the former going to
dark on and the latter going to gleam so
if you take out too many black spirits
then galine will win and if you take out
too many white ones then dark on will
make sense
good now shut up and listen after
ultimately battling two clones of the
crazy and Master Hand the real versions
will appear on the board allowing you to
battle them and free them from the
controls of their represses they will
travel to the top of the board punch a
hole in reality and open up a new area
for the players to travel to and
interact with doing this will allow
players to take control of the master
hand and fight both dark and light
copies of the playable characters this
is the first time in the series that
players have been able to do this and it
makes for one hell of an encounter from
here players will have to battle dark on
and gleam at the same time this is one
hell of a battle that will smash you
harder than you should smash the like
button on this video and it will really
test your mastering of the game and is
easily the hardest fight in it those who
make it through that all-out slugfest
will witness both beings being defeated
and watch as they fall into the ocean
from there both of them will explode
releasing all the spirits that they took
under their control these spirits will
imply into space forming a beautiful ray
of energy that for once doesn't wipe out
the galaxy and that's the ending of the
game mario & co saved the universe and
defeat both darken and gleam in one
final swoop obviously I'd love to hear
your thoughts on the finale as well as
which one you got so make sure you leave
a comment below
discussing the game if you enjoyed this
video then please like it and check out
my breakdown of this yes other big game
Red Dead Redemption 2 which will be
linked at the end this is a channel for
the hardcore players so if that's the
kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]